Biodiversität das sind nicht drei Sorten
Hackfleisch im Kühlregal sondern das was
uns am Leben hält man könnte sogar sagen
die
biodiversitätskrise ist die große
Schwester der Klimakrise in den letzten
100 Jahren sind so viele Arten
ausgestorben die sonst in tausenden von
Jahren nicht und dabei geht es nicht um
ein paar Insekten weniger auf der
Windschutzscheibe denn von der Luft zum
Atmen über eine gesunde Verdauung bis
hin zum Schokoladengenuss unser
Wohlstand und unsere Gesundheit sind
komplett abhängig von funktionierenden
Ökosystemen und bad news es gibt einen
tipppunkt an dem alles zusammenbrechen
wird dann wir den erreichen genau darum
geht es jetzt
wir Menschen sehen uns ja gerne als
unabhängig von der Natur aber sowohl wir
als auch jedes andere Lebewesen sind auf
Dienste angewiesen die die Ökosysteme
für uns leisten der Grund für diese
Abhängigkeit ist dass sich alles Leben
gemeinsam entwickelt hat und sich auf
die Anwesenheit anderer Arten verletzt
der Mensch ist sogar selbst ein
Ökosystem auf in und von ihm leben
unzählige Kleinstlebewesen zum Beispiel
hautmilben von den hier zum Glück
meistens nichts merken oder
Darmbakterien eine Studie fand sogar
heraus dass jeder von uns seine ganz
individuelle mikrobenwolke ausstößt haha
in einem Ökosystem zum Beispiel dem
Dschungel oder der Savanne verlassen
sich die Arten aufeinander die
Darmbakterien bekommen eine geschützte
Umgebung mit reichlich Nahrung und wir
wiederum verlassen uns unter anderem
darauf dass Sie unsere Nahrung für uns
mit verdauen danke schön und genau so
verlassen wir uns auf eine ganze Menge
anderer Dienstleistungen der Natur zum
Beispiel auf die Entsorgung mit
Vitaminen die unser Körper nicht selbst
bildet er verlässt sich stattdessen
darauf dass sie in den Lebewesen sind
die wir essen und die Lebewesen die wir
essen sind ebenfalls abhängig von noch
mal anderen Arten zum Beispiel sind mehr
als 3/4 der weltweit angebauten
Pflanzenarten teilweise oder sogar ganz
auf die Bestäubung durch Tiere
angewiesen ohne diese Bestäuber wären
Ernten im Gegenwert von rund 280 bis 690
Milliarden Euro gefährdet zum Beispiel
Kakao es gibt sehr viele solcher
Ökosystem Dienstleistungen und nur ein
paar wenige davon lassen sich so
wirklich in Geld bewerten aber sie
betreffen alle Bereiche unseres Lebens
sie liefern Rohstoffe und
Produktionsmittel regulieren
Temperaturen säubern die Atmosphäre
Gewässer und Böden geben uns Nahrung und
natürlich sind wir auch einfach gerne in
der Natur letztes Jahr hat die
Weltbevölkerung die 8 Milliarden
überschritten den Zenit erwartet die UN
bei 10,4 Milliarden und hier kommt das
große Problem all diese 10, Milliarden
Menschen brauchen funktionierende
Ökosystem Dienstleistungen und die sind
jetzt schon massiv gefährdet und können
plötzlich zusammenbrechen auch da wo es
vielleicht gar nicht danach aussieht
aber bevor wir dazu kommen müssen wir
erst einmal verstehen dass Ökosysteme
Netzwerke sind
Ökosysteme sind komplexe Systeme und das
ist nicht nur eine treffende
Beschreibung sondern tatsächlich ein
Fachbegriff aus der Systemtheorie auch
das Wettersystem und das Gehirn sind
komplexe Systeme für uns bedeutet das
sie sind schwierig zu beschreiben zu
analysieren und vorherzusagen Komplex
eben allein die einzelnen Teile eines
Ökosystems also die einzelnen Arten zu
finden zu bestimmen und zu zählen ist
super viel Arbeit zwar sind bis heute
bereits 2,1 Millionen Arten bekannt aber
ob das 25% oder sogar nur 2,5% aller
existierenden Arten sind das scheint
niemand wirklich zu wissen um einen
Ökosystem zu beschreiben müssen die
Forschenden mit Kameras Mikrofonen
fallen Kasern Ferngläsern looten
Mikroskopen und sogar gehen Analysen
jedem Hinweis nachgehen und jeden
Quadratmeter untersuchen so kommen
allein in einem Ökosystem oft tausende
von Arten zusammen und das war der
einfache Teil jetzt muss man von dieser
Art noch wissen was sie für
Eigenschaften hat und welche
Wechselbeziehungen sie mit den anderen
Arten eingeht und da gibt es praktisch
unendlich viele Möglichkeiten mal ist
die Wechselbeziehung zum gegenseitigen
Vorteil zum Beispiel wenn Ameisen
Blattläuse pflegen und beschützen um
ihre süßen Sekrete zu naschen mal
profitiert eine Seite während die andere
geschädigt wird zum Beispiel wenn Pilze
Ameisen zu willenlosen Zombies machen
und sie danach umbringen und mal stehen
die beiden Seiten in Konkurrenz zum
Beispiel wenn verschiedene Ameisenarten
und Kolonien und Territorien kämpfen aus
diesem Beispielen lernen wir erstens
Ameisen sind super interessant und mega
cool und zweitens so ein Ökosystem wird
es sehr schnell unübersichtlich kein
Mensch kann sich das alles merken
deshalb setzt man auf Computermodelle
aber selbst Supercomputer können die
gesamte Komplexität der Wirklichkeit
nicht abbilden okay gut die Ökosysteme
sind also total komplex und schwierig zu
verstehen
aber das Gefährliche an komplexen
Netzwerken ist nicht nur dass wir sehr
lange brauchen um sie auch nur halbwegs
zu durchblicken ihre Komplexität gibt
Ihnen auch eine sehr trügerische
Eigenschaft man sieht ihnen nämlich
nicht unbedingt an wenn sie kurz vor
einem katastrophalen Zusammenbruch
stehen das kann man sich so vorstellen
man hat ein Ökosystem in dem viele Arten
voneinander abhängig sind jetzt verliert
man eine Art nach der anderen und
zunächst passiert erstmal nicht viel
denn je mehr Arten im System sind desto
eher kann das Aussterben einzelne Arten
abgefedert werden sagen wir aber jetzt
die Anzahl an Arten sind weiterhin
konsumierlich dann erreichen wir
irgendwann einen Punkt an dem der
Verlust einer Art nicht mehr durch eine
andere Art aufgefangen werden kann wie
ein jenger Turm fällt dann alles in sich
zusammen und plötzlich sterben viele
Arten auf einmal aus das ist der
Kipppunkt an dem es kein Zurück mehr
gibt das ganze Ökosystem geht
unwiderbringlich verloren und damit auch
seine Dienstleistungen von denen wir
abhängig sind die Widerstand Kraft der
Ökosysteme entsteht also durch die
Vielfalt der Ökosysteme die Vielfalt der
Arten und die genetische Vielfalt
zusammen all das ist die Biodiversität
und genau diese Biodiversität geht
gerade rasant den Bach runter
seit vorgeschichtlicher Zeit jagt der
Mensch Tiere bis zur Ausrottung als
Nahrungsmittel Medizin Jagdtrophäen oder
Haustiere große gesunde Exemplare
exotischer und seltener Tiere sind hoch
und Kurs auch die Meere sind vor uns
nicht sicher die meisten Fischbestände
sind stark befrischt und oft auch schon
über fischt mit unseren Reisen rund um
die Welt verschleppen wir meistens
unabsichtlich Arten von ihrer Heimat in
neue Lebensräume wenn sie dort optimale
Bedingungen und keine Fressfeinde
vorfinden werden sie zur invasiven
Spezies die die heimischen Arten
ausrottet hinzu kommt die
Umweltbelastung durch die moderne
Industrie jedes Jahr produzieren wir
rund 400 Millionen Tonnen Plastik dazu
kommen Abgase Industrieabfälle und
Pestizide die in der Umwelt landen wir
haben jetzt zum Beispiel schon ein Video
über den Sauen Regen in Deutschland
gemacht noch schlimmer als das ist die
sich immer weiter ausbreitende
Landnutzung mehr als ein Drittel der
Landmasse und 75% der Süßwasser
vorkommen benutzen wir alleine für
Landwirtschaft hinzu kommen unsere
Siedlungen Industrieanlagen und
Verkehrswege Wälder werden gerodet more
trockengelegt Flüsse begradigt die
heimischen Pflanzen und Tiere verlieren
ihren Lebensraum und dann ist da ja noch
der menschengemachte Klimawandel Tiere
und Pflanzen besetzen eine individuelle
klimanische das heißt sie haben
Wohlfühlbereiche für Temperatur
Feuchtigkeit Niederschlag und
Lichteinstrahlung wenn sich die
Klimazonen nun schneller verändern als
Tiere und Pflanzen nachziehen oder sich
anpassen können kann sterben sie aus und
auch der Mensch selbst ist betroffen die
mit Abstand meisten Menschen leben in
einer recht klar umgrenzten klimanische
und auch die bewegt sich nicht
bevölkerte Gebiete in Indien und
Südostasien zum Beispiel werden für
Menschen unfreundlicher anders als die
meisten Wildtiere und Pflanzen können
Menschen natürlich wegziehen und das
werden sie müssen wenn Ihre Gesundheit
gefährdet wird und die Landwirtschaft in
der Region sie nicht mehr ernähren kann
das Problem ist dass da wo sie hinziehen
schon andere Menschen leben und das
erzeugt natürlich Konflikte all diese
Faktoren tragen zu einem nie gesehenen
Artensterben bei
42.000 Arten sind vom Aussterben bedroht
und dabei wurden nur knapp über sieben
Prozent aller bekannten Arten überhaupt
überprüft mehrere studienweisen darauf
hin dass die Aussterberate extrem hoch
ist nämlich 100 bis 1000 Mal so hoch wie
im Mittel der letzten 10 Millionen Jahre
unter den Säugetieren machen Wildtiere
nur noch 4% der Biomasse aus 96% fallen
auf Menschen und ihre Haustiere schon
seit 1995 spricht man sogar von einem
großen Massensterben das heißt man
erwartet dass mehr als 70% der Arten in
relativ kurzer Zeit Aussterben solche
Ereignisse gab es vorher nur fünfmal der
Impact der Menschen auf die Natur ist
also in der gleichen Kategorie wie der
Meteorit der vor 66 Millionen Jahren bis
auf die Vögel alle Dinosaurier und noch
sehr viele weitere Arten ausgelöscht hat
es hat rund 11 bis 12 Millionen Jahre
gedauert bis sich die aussterben und neu
entstehungsraten wieder normalisiert
hatten und eins ist klar diese Zeit
haben wir nicht
also was tun
zurück zu den Computermodellen die
Forscherinnen und Forscher benutzen um
Ökosysteme besser zu verstehen natürlich
versuchen die Forschenden jetzt
herauszufinden wie sehr wir das
planetare System schon jetzt an seine
Grenzen gebracht haben dass das bei so
komplexen Systemen fast unmöglich ist
haben wir jetzt etabliert aber
vielleicht gibt es da doch irgendwo
einen guten Weg eine Schätzung zu machen
wenn man nicht das ganze System sondern
nur einige seiner Teile modelliert das
kennt ihr bestimmt aus der Klima Debatte
die lokale Wettervorhersage ist immer
nur ein paar Tage in die Zukunft gültig
und man benötigt exakte Daten für die
Modellierung aber für Klima Modelle muss
man nicht jedes Detail messen das
reichen Messungen von relativ wenigen
Faktoren die über 30 Jahre und die ganze
Welt gemittelt werden so werden die
Trends auf großer Skala und lange Sicht
vorhersehbar man will den Wald sehen
nicht lauter Bäume in einer kürzlich
veröffentlichten Studie zum Beispiel
argumentieren die Forscher dass wir
genug über Landwirbeltiere Wissen um
realistische Prognosen über deren
Biodiversität machen zu können statt
echte Tierarten zu modellieren haben sie
im Computer eine Erde nachgebaut die sie
dann mit künstlichen Landwirbeltieren
bevölkert haben jede Tierart hat unter
anderem eine definierte Körpergröße
klimanische und Nahrungsbedürfnisse
viele zehntausende dieser Tierarten hat
das Modell dann zu Ökosystemen
zusammengestellt und dann mit realen
Daten abgeglichen auf diese künstliche
Welt haben Sie dann die gängigen
Klimamodelle und Daten zu erwarteten
Landnutzung angewandt um die Zeit von
2020 bis 2100 zu simulieren das alles
haben sie für drei klimazenarien jeweils
100 mal neu gemacht
dabei kam heraus dass die
Landwirbeltiere bis 2100 wahrscheinlich
17% ihrer Biodiversität verlieren werden
das alleine ist schon mega schlimm aber
noch schlimmer ist dass die einzelnen
Ökosysteme wahrscheinlich bis zu 50%
ihrer ökologischen Wechselbeziehungen
verlieren also genau das was ein
Ökosystem stabil macht das heißt ein
kleiner Verlust an Biodiversität bewirkt
einen großen Verlust an Stabilität
rückt der katastrophale Zusammenbruch
des Systems also schneller näher als wir
es ahnen können
fest steht dass wir die Ökosysteme
zurzeit extrem belasten und es ist klar
dass irgendwann der Punkt kommt an dem
sie kippen werden wie kurz die einzelnen
Systeme jeweils vor ihrem Kipppunkt
stehen ist schwierig bis unmöglich zu
sagen mit Modellen und Wissen über die
Klima Nischen der Ökosysteme versucht
man aber es so gut wie möglich
abzuschätzen die gefährdeten Ökosysteme
sind dabei die tropischen Korallenriffe
laut ipc-bericht könnten sie bereits in
wenigen Jahrzehnten durch die langen
Hitzewellen zerstört werden und mit
ihnen verschwindet die Lebensgrundlage
für viele Fische von denen die Menschen
in den nahegelegenen Küstenregionen
leben die aber auch wir hier in
Deutschland zum Beispiel in unserem
Kühltruhen finden
das sind die schlechten Nachrichten
optimistisch gesehen trägt aber
natürlich die Bekämpfung des
Klimawandels auch zum Schutz der
Biodiversität bei und umgekehrt denn
sterbende Ökosysteme setzen CO2 frei
aber sich erholende Ökosysteme speichern
CO2 besonders schwierig wird die
Umstellung der Landwirtschaft auf der
einen Seite ist die intensive
Landwirtschaft Teil des Problems weil
sie die Böden auslaugt auf der anderen
Seite hat sie die Landnutzung pro Kopf
kontinuierlich verringert im Dezember
bei der UN
bio-universitätskonferenz in Montreal
wurden Maßnahmen beschlossen die das
menschengemachte Arten sterben bis 2050
beenden sollen zu den konkreten
Beschlüssen gehört unter anderem 30% der
Erde unter Schutz zu stellen und 30% der
Geschädigten Ökosysteme
wiederherzustellen wenn wir das
hinbekommen dann können wir vielleicht
endlich etwas aufatmen das muss aber
auch passieren zum Beispiel in dem
bedrohte Tierarten aktiv wieder
zurückgebracht werden indem wir die
Ozeane von Plastik befreien und
Waldflächen renaturieren genau das und
vieles mehr macht eine neue Initiative
mit dem Namen Planet wild die im
Frühjahr startet und bei der ich sogar
persönlich ein bisschen involviert bin
Planet wild ist eine Community aus
Menschen die der Natur etwas zurückgeben
möchte mit Beiträgen der Mitglieder
werden weltweit zentrale
naturschutzmissionen umgesetzt die
effektiv Ökosysteme stabilisieren und
Tiere schützen das ganze wird dann
transparent in spannenden Videos
dokumentiert wenn ihr mehr erfahren
wollt könnt ihr unter dem Link in der
Beschreibung einen ersten Blick auf die
Initiative werfen und der Warteliste
beitreten ich habe bereits die Bilder
der ersten Mission gesehen und ich kann
nur sagen es lohnt sich wie immer vielen
Dank fürs zuschauen und bleibt neugierig
euer Cedric